hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to destiny rebellion
okay we're actually gonna get along with
the story here like the actual story
story now I know I haven't been doing
this because I've been very interesting
and what this story has to have in a
unique sense in the optional content but
that does not mean that the actual story
will not have very interesting stuff to
it so we're gonna get into that right
now apparently
oh my well even the fake key cannot open
this but the nuclear rods seems to be
somewhere else
oh hi well okay then
nice bass death bass okay so jeez what
the hell happened here
this is cracks all over the walls hello
did I hear something I thought I heard
something these tender boxes are
everywhere but they're hard to see
they're so small and insignificant their
eyes easy to overlook hi buddy
bernhard von bülow cool German Empire
and all that okay I'm gonna be very
upset if I check the description or the
comments after I finished recording this
and uploading it that oh hi and if I
miss tiny box stem I'm at Ojai I'm gonna
be very upset how painful and dark times
came to this land I don't even remember
seeing anybody happy that Ralph
Cifaretto
poor boy he became a widower in such a
young age no sign of happiness ever
since that event he's studying every
single day and every evening he goes to
the graveyard I adore his hard
determination to continue living
I cannot say so myself looks like the
plague has already gotten to me I feel
extremely cold my whole body hurts I
even see hallucinations too bad for me
that I don't have any relatives or
friends to burry my old rotten body okay
sorry old man looks like you're just
gonna have to die alone oh wait a minute
I got a nuclear rod but
anyways what what is that are those
fingers that is damn disgusting what am
I looking at here
oh it's a quilt nevermind I guess I
could have turned on my lamp and at any
point checked on what that really was I
think this guy's lots of tinderboxes
hope you don't mind old man I'm robbing
you of all your possessions I'm out of
here baby
I'm out of here I got me a nuclear rod
will well I guess I guess I was it
what other point did I am for going in
there I have no idea anyway this is all
part of chapter one there is like six
other chapters as a part of this game so
this game is actually quite long so I'm
hoping I'm very much hoping that in the
grand scheme of things there going to be
a lot of more interesting content
because is it this is all just part of
the first chapter ah a lot of time and
effort went into these pieces hello
hello oh man so much time and effort
went into these sorry my apologies oh
these are such delicate knickknacks
goodbye oh look at this tiny pig or cow
or whatever you go and doggie cool okay
is there a tiny box here
has anybody seen it - oh nice big blue
balls um other than that I didn't see
anything go by have fun with the rest of
your life I'm gonna continue on to the
rest of this story how about this one
haunted house
whoo I like the sound of that one are we
gonna have some scares you are some
delightful delicious scares Oh Oh
Oh Isaac felt a chill run down my spine
god this guy really likes to play with
miniatures this is really cool there's a
lot of tiny stuff but no tiny box with
which I would love to have company hello
good one okay okay sorry what did I do
oh hi where did you come from you douche
pan uh yeah yeah I know I know
I know you don't like me I don't like
you either but I'm gonna carry on and do
other stuff oh you are not welcome here
okay thank you I think I could tell by
that guy oh hi oh I get the funny
feeling that I'm not welcome here laughs
god damn ding-dong damn it you stop it
with that it's with the weird spinning
table legs hi hello good thing they got
a medkit for me but I have a feeling
this old place was used for scientific
experiments oh hi that's gross
sorry laughs god damn it screw you and
your stupid-ass things what is this
Rick's what is there bricks here oh god
damn it I wasn't ready for this I was
having such a happy fun time and all
sudden you throw the dastardly
devilishness at me one tinderbox that
was all that was for I got like 1,900
boxes just from that one guy why do I
need from you
hello I bought this house several weeks
ago I was quite cheap with previous
owner and disappeared without a trace
they said that some murders occurred in
this house at first everything seemed to
be fine until I discovered that
something is really wrong all right
every night I started to feel for my
life I hear those screeching sounds and
frightened I heard steps I hope that
things will not find me under my bed
under oh they found him things found him
under his bed oh my I'm gonna clear this
out for when I run into it screaming
like a little baby I'm not gonna block
the doorways so that I can hide into it
screaming like a little baby okay that's
cool I shouldn't use so much my lantern
but I'm what what stop it with the
ambience that ambience is gonna kill me
that douche still upstairs
cool I can play one note no matter which
one I hit that's cool
is he still up there I hope not cuz I'm
coming up moving on up do these oh my
god
okay everything got inverted oh my god
what is happening to me why is this
happening where in the world is just a
thing oh my god okay everything is lit
my mouse is completely flipped I all got
even my directions are flipped Oh
criminy Christmas okay
Oh God oh I can't I can't walk like this
I can't move
hello don't move okay that's cool too
why I have to ask why that's an okay
okay okay everything's back to normal
oh my god why did I go in there what did
I do that
give me my sanity up please stop with
the wibbly-wobbly I would really
appreciate all God is dark oh god why am
i stepping in water what is wrong with
this I want to go home oh hi so hello
baby oh I was worried for a second but
now you're you with me oh you looking so
good I haven't seen you in ages baby oh
oh hello baby I didn't see its win over
there but I'm glad you're over here to
keep me nice oh yeah okay so Dada what
did I do
no no checkpoint
no thank you I don't want any my babies
who keep me nice and safe don't worry I
got a sward darling
I'll protect you from the evil monster
out there oh you want me to you you you
you want me to go charging in after him
huh well no I'm not a coward my vision
just a little bit wonky oh yeah oh hi oh
hi
I'll get him baby oh okay
is he here is he actually here okay my
vision okay here where is he
what's going on oh he's here I saw him
gonna see okay eyes on okay yes I saw
him yes that was it yes that's a
definite yes
okay that's bad that's bad that's very
bad Oh God
bathtub full blood brine out where I
wanted to be such a button valve give me
a nice warm bath to wash away the
memories this horrible place
good god this is the scariest part near
me gee I've ever played okay I don't
know what that did I'm so sorry
what happened the music keeps like
blaring and changing I have no idea if
it's all good all good and what is this
a painting of wait what can I flip it
over what is going on here okay got it
order okay never mind okay tonight's
weather is stormy I fear storms I wanted
to go to daddy's room but I saw a scary
shadow near the stairway I ran away from
the boogeyman crying in tears I hid in
the bathroom now I'm too frightened to
leave I still hear those screeching
sound it's coming I must hide in the
bathtub
I don't wanna die Oh No
okay that wasn't terribly scary but you
almost startled me
you almost startled me okay
you almost got y'all grab okay good
there's no water okay
I really should use my really should use
my tinderboxes more is he still out
there okay yeah you still out there
where is he oh he's right there that was
a bad idea okay I need to do something
not going that psycho room again there
had to be another room in here than I
need to go through and here maybe Wow
okay thank you for getting me away from
the douche that guy is not happy about
losing me
hello or loose man avoid the contact
these plants produce vast amount of
poisonous liquid it is not lethal but it
makes you suffer and makes your skin
burn just be sure not to touch it
okay can I get the nuclear rod and get
out of here at all
what the hell is that how my throat oh
my god
it's 90 bucks Jim Oh what does this even
do okay there we go there we go oh my
god you're even tinier than I remember
Oh Danny bucks too this is a bad place
this is a bad place have you seen
anything going on here Tennyson
oh yeah there's monsters everywhere you
[ __ ] I know Danny bikes him I know I
found them but it's okay because we're
gonna be here together oh I think I saw
something
throw me off the tacit rare good job
tiny box Jim you really showed him what
for Oh is there someone making fun of
you over there y'all don't worry about
that what was that tiny bud sim like a
pig oh okay good job tiny bug sim we're
gonna get this all sorted out a nuclear
odd good job tiny much stem you found it
I was on you markiplier you're great
thank you I know now let's get out of
here we gotta go okay
gosh you're so tiny beautiful I love you
so much now let's get out of here this
place is dangerous we gotta keep moving
or else we'll die
I believe in you markiplier more than
anything I love you oh that ain't good
I don't think anyone read this but I
must before what's happening here no
matter who you are make sure not to stay
them not here at night my investigation
revealed many supernatural phenomena in
this house I can't explain it any other
way the curse things are despairity
moving on their own starting strange
screaming's outshines by the poisons
plant critter a detective eh
well that doesn't sound good but I think
he's still upstairs so I think I'm okay
okay
there's an open door over here oh is
this way out I think this might be the
way out
let's get out of here tiny box Tim oh no
but tiny box Tim how will I take you
with me no it's okay
I'll stay here and defeat the monsters
no Danny but still I love you I can't
leave you like this
you know you asked to do it I'm the only
one that can stop them no Danny much do
please please stay come with me
we can live together we can be happy I
will always be in your heart
oh I love you Jenny bucks Tim I love you
too now get out of here too late I will
always remember you as I get the hell
out of here oh it wasn't quite the exit
yet you bastard you left it in the other
room oh it's okay you'll do fine on your
own
bye no I left you bye
No I love to bide he was even tinier
than I remember it was tinier box Tim oh
so tiny and I loved him so oh well
anyway I'll see him again in the future
I'm sure and then you guys will see him
again the future if you know what I mean
you don't know what I mean but you'll
know what I mean soon enough so anyway
thank you all so much for watching this
because of story is amazing
I can't wait to turn this into however
long it takes to play I don't care I'm
playing the whole damn thing so anyway
thank you all so much for watching let
me know what you think of our reunion
with tiny box Tim in the comments below
leave a like if you're enjoying this
series it would really mean a lot to me
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
serious where's this boom holy cow